سكان مدينه اسطنبول يخططون للانتقال خوفا
من زلزال مدمر
[موسيقى]
ابناء هاري وميجان يحصلان على لقب امير
واميره رغم كل الخلافات
وحمامه مجهزه بكاميرا ورقاقه الكترونيه
تثير حيره الشرطه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
بعد ورود تقارير تتحدث عن زلزال مدمر
محتمل في مدينه اسطنبول بقوه سبع درجات
قرر عدد من سكان اسطنبول للانتقاله الى
ولايات مجاوره العالم البيئي التركي
جونارلي العربيه نت ان اعدادا قليله فقط
من سكان اسطنبول حاليا انتقلوا الى مدن او
ولايات اخرى داخل تركيا مشيرا الى ان
اخرين استعدوا لمواجهه الزلزال عبر تجهيز
مركباتهم للنوم فيها حال وقوعه او صنعي
غرف حديديه مقاومه للزلازل واضاف ان كل
هؤلاء اعدادهم ضئيله مقارنه بملايين
السكان في المدينه التي تعد ثاني اكبر
المدن التركيه
ونبقى في الاخبار المتعلقه بالزلازل
والهزات حيث عاد الباحث الهولندي فرانك
هوجربتس ليتصدر حديث السوشيال ميديا وذلك
بعد توقعه حدوث زلزال وسط تركيا اليوم
الخميس المركز الاوروبي المتوسطي لرصد
الزلازل اعلن ان هزه ارضيه بقوه 3.7 درجات
على مقياس ريختر ضربت بالفعل وسط تركيا
على عمق خمسه كيلومترات وذلك بعد ساعات
قليله من توقع الباحث الهولندي في المقابل
واجه الاخير موجه من الانتقادات لم تخلو
من السخريه على السوشيال ميديا بعد فشل
توقعاته بحدوث زلزال مدمر وهائل في
المنطقه بتاريخ السادس والسابع من مارسا
الجعلي
رغم كل الخلافات الحاصله مع العائله
الملكيه تم تسميه ارشي ابن الامير هاري
وزوجته ميجا ماركل وكذلك ابنتهما
كاميره واميره على الموقع الالكتروني لقصر
الامريكيه افادت بانه تم ادراج الامير
ارتي ذوقس وشقيقته
في المرتبه السادسه والسابعه على التوالي
تحت خط خلافه العرش البريطاني على الموقع
فيما ياتي هذا التغيير بعدما اشار الامير
هاري وزوجته ميجا ماركل الى كاميره لاول
مره علنا بمناسبه معموديتها
افاد تقرير استخباراتي بان منشا فيروس
كورونا لا يزال مجهولا مشيرا الى عدم وجود
توافق بالاراء بشان اصوله وكاله بلومبورج
نقلت عن تقرير لمكتب مدير الاستخبارات
الوطنيه قدم الى لجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس
الشيوخ قوله ان كل الوكالات تقدر ان
فرضيتين فقط معقولتين لاصل منشا كورونا
اما التواصل مع حيوان مصاب او حادث تسرب
مختبري واضاف التقرير ان وكالات
الاستخبارات تواصل التحقيق في كيفيه اصابه
البشر بالفيروس لاول مره وفقا للتقييم
الذي لم يتغير عن العام الماضي
وفي خبرنا الاخير تناقلت وسائل الاعلام
هنديه خبرا وصف بالغريب يفيد بعثور صيادين
على حمامه جاسوسه علمتني سفينتهم الراسيه
قرب ساحل كونارك بولايه اوديشا تقارير
ذكرت ان الحمامه كانت مزوده بكاميرا ورقات
الكترونيه لحظه اصطيادها مشيره الى ان
الشرطه تشتبه في ان هذا الطائر كان يستخدم
في التجسس واشارت معلومات الى ان الاطباء
البيطريين سيفحصون الطائر وسيقوم مختبر
الطب الشرعي كذلك بفحص الاجهزه المتصله
بساق الحمامه في محاوله للكشف عن مصدرها